yes please okay well welcome everyone to
today's meeting of the licensing
subcommittee
prior to the meeting all participants
will check that they can be seen and
heard and can see and hear
other members to double check this
institute
introduce everyone who is present at
this remote meeting
i will kindly ask that you confirm your
attendance and your role or job
title when i say your name so can i
start with mrs brock
technical support team manager
thank you mrs stalker good morning
everyone alison stocker senior licensing
officer fannie district council
thank you mrs mario good morning
everyone jade manny licensed in officer
and mr scrote thank you chair morgan
sprouts regulatory services manager
fanuc council
and mrs barry good morning amanda perry
senior environmental protection officer
thank you mrs phillips good morning
jennifer phillips the principal
litigation lawyer for authority council
um
good morning pc greg kemp police
licensed officer
thank you this
is division
thank you p.s beresford
okay mr craig
good morning everybody i'm here i just
want to check if my
clients hear us today he was my next one
to ask mr day
good morning yet i'm here matthew day uh
licensed holder at dave's girls
i just couldn't see him on the screen
anywhere thank you
lovely have i missed anyone present
today
okay well if you have technical
different difficulties during this
meeting
then please contact the democratic
services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you they will
put their phone number in the chat
function
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking to please mute your
microphone
this does minimize the background noise
as you would have heard earlier
and help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen screen
and i will make a note and go back to
you
once the person speaking has finished
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
do not turn off your phones in case you
need to be contacted
in the event of technical difficulties
please
also refrain from checking emails or
conducting other businesses
business and ensure that you are in a
quiet room free from distractions for
the duration of the meeting
okay we're going to agenda item one
apologies for
absence are there any apologies for
absence
no i've received okay agenda item two
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
okay agenda item three exclusion of
press and public
um obviously we've only got two of us
here so can i have one of us to propose
and the other to second
that the public and press be excluded
from the meeting for a gender item
for as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraphs four and seven
of part one of schedule 12a of the local
government act
1972 as amended
thank proposed thank you councillor wing
and i'll second
we're now going to agenda item 4
application